could be a threat to the progress that
we've made as a nation
we're entering the winter in a strong
position thanks to the decisions we made
in the summer and the defenses that we
have built
our vaccination program has been moving
at a blistering pace and this weekend we
reached the Milestone of 17 million
boosters across the UK
this means that even though cases have
been rising Hospital admissions have
fallen a further 11 in the past week and
deaths have fallen by 17 percent
but just as the vaccination program has
shifted the odds in our favor a worrying
new variant has always had the
opportunity to shift them back
last week I was alerted to what is now
known as the Omicron variant now
designated a variant of concern by the
World Health Organization
we're learning more about this new
variant all the time
but the latest indication is that it
spreads very rapidly
it may impact the effectiveness of one
of our major treatments for covid-19
rhonoprive and as the chief medical
officer said this weekend there's a
reasonable chance that our current
vaccines may be impacted
I can update the house that there have
now been five confirmed cases in England
and also six confirmed cases in Scotland
and we expect cases to rise over the
coming days
Garrett has also been spreading across
the world
confirmed cases have been reported in
many countries including Austria Belgium
the Czech Republic Denmark Germany Italy
the Netherlands and Portugal
in this race between the vaccines and
the virus the new varied may have given
the virus extra links
so our strategy is to buy ourselves time
and to strengthen our defenses while our
world leading scientists learn more
about this Potential Threat
on Friday I updated the house about the
measures we've put in place
including how within hours we'd play six
countries in southern Africa on the
Travel Red List
today Mr Speaker I'd like to update the
house on a more balanced and
proportionate steps that we are taking
first
measures at the border to slow the
incursion of the variant from abroad
on Saturday in line with the updated
advice from the UK Health Security
Agency we acted quickly to add four
other countries to the travel Red List
Angola Mozambique Malawi and Zambia
this means that anyone who's not a UK or
Irish National or resident
who's been in any of these countries
over the previous 10 days will be
refused entry
on those who are allowed entry must
isolate in a government-approved
facility for 10 days
Beyond this red list we're also going
further to put in place a proportionate
testing regime for arrivals from across
the world
so we'll require anyone who enters the
UK to take a PCR test by the end of
their second day after they arrive
and to self-isolate until they receive a
negative result
the regulations for this have been laid
before the house today and will come
into effect at 4am tomorrow
second we've announced measures to slow
the spread of the virus here in the UK
we're making changes to our rules on
self-isolation for close contacts in
England to reflect the greater threat
that may be posed by this new variant
so close contacts of anyone who tests
positive with a suspected case of
Omicron must self-isolate for 10 days
regardless of whether they have been
vaccinated or not
face coverings will also be made
compulsory in shops and on public
transport in England unless an
individual has a medical exemption
the regulations for self-isolation and
face coverings have been laid before the
house today and will come into fourth at
4am tomorrow but I can confirm to the
house that there will be a debate and
votes on these two measures to give the
house the opportunity to have it say and
to perform valuable scrutiny my right
honorable friend the leader of the house
will be setting out more detail shortly
and will be reviewing all of these
measures that I've set out today after
three weeks to see whether they are
still necessary
third Mr Speaker we're strengthening the
defenses we've built against the virus
we're already in a stronger position
than we were when we Face the Delta
variant
we have a much greater capacity for
testing
an enhanced ability for sequencing
and the collective protection that's
offered by 114 million Jabs in arms
and so I would like to update the house
on our vaccination program as well
our covid-19 vaccination program has
been a national success story we've
delivered more booster doses than
anywhere else in Europe and we've given
Top-Up jobs to over one in three people
over the age of 18 across the United
Kingdom
I'd like to take this opportunity to pay
tribute to the NHS the volunteers the
armed forces and everyone else that has
been involved in this life-saving work
our vaccines remain our best line of
defense against this virus in whatever
form it attacks us
there's a lot we don't know about how
our vaccine responds to this new variant
but although it's possible that they may
be less effective it's highly unlikely
they will have no effectiveness at all
against serious disease so it's really
important that we get as many Jabs in
arms as possible
over the next few weeks we were already
planning to do six million booster jobs
in England alone
but against this backdrop of this new
variant we want to go further and faster
so I asked the jcvi the government's
independent expert advisors on
vaccinations to urgently review how we
could expand the program and whether we
should reduce the gap between second
Doses and boosters
the jcvi published its advice in the
last hour
first it advised that the minimum dose
interval for booster Jabs should be
halved from 6 months to three months
second that the booster program should
be expanded to include all remaining
adults aged 18 and above
third that these boosters should be
offered by age group in a descending
order to protect those who are most
vulnerable to the virus
so priority will be given to older
adults and people over 16 who are at
risk
fourth that severely immunosuppressed
people age 16 or above who've received
three primary doses
should now also be offered a booster
dose
finally that children aged between 12
and 15 should be given a second dose 12
weeks from the first dose
I have accepted this advice in full
with this new variant on the offensive
these measures will protect more people
more quickly and make us better
protected as a nation
it represents a huge step up for our
vaccination program almost doubling the
number of people who will be able to get
a booster dose to protect themselves and
their loved ones
and I know
that we are asking more from NHS
colleagues who've already given us so
much throughout this crisis but I know
that they will be up to the task
the NHS will be calling people forward
at the appropriate time so that those
who are most vulnerable will be
prioritized and I'll be sending out more
details of how we are putting this
advice into action in the coming days
Mr Speaker our fight against this virus
is a global effort and so I'd like to
update the house on the part that the UK
is playing we currently hold the
presidency of the G7 and earlier today I
convened an urgent meeting of G7 Health
ministers to coordinate the
international response
we were unanimous in our praise for the
leadership shown by South Africa who
were so open and transparent about this
new variant
and we were Resolute in our commitment
to working closely with each other the
World Health Organization and of course
the wider International Community to
tackle this common thread
Mr Speaker our experience of fighting
this virus has shown us that it's best
to act decisively and swiftly when we
see a Potential Threat which is why
we're building our defenses and putting
these measures in place without delay
scientists are working at speed at home
and abroad to determine whether this
variant is more dangerous and I can
assure the house that if it emerges that
this variant is no more dangerous than
the Delta variant then we won't keep
measures in place for a day longer than
necessary
covid-19 is not going away
and so we'll have to keep seeing new
variants emerge
so if we want to live with the virus for
the long term we must follow the
evidence and act in a proportionate and
responsible way if a variant has the
potential to thwart our progress
and as we do this
we are taking a well-rounded view
looking not just the at the impact of
these measures of the virus
but uh the impact to the economy to
education and non-covered health such as
mental health
and I'm confident that these responses
that we've set out today are they are
balanced and responsible steps that are
proportionate to the threat that we face
Mr Speaker this year our nation has come
so far down our road of recovery but we
always knew that there would be bumps in
the road
but this is not a time to waver it's a
time to be vigilant and to think about
what each and every one of us can do to
slow the spread of this new variant
getting a jab when the time comes
following the rules that we've put in
place
and getting rapid regular tests
if we all come together once again then
we can keep this virus at Bay and
protect the progress that we have made a
tremendous statement to the house
shuttle Minister Dr Russell
thank you Mr Speaker and I'd like to
start by sending my best wishes to the
shadow Secretary of State who cannot be
here as he is currently off with covid
and we all hope he gets better soon
I'd like to thank the Secretary of State
for advanced sight of his statement
this variant is a wake-up call
the pandemic is not over
we need to act with speed to bolster our
defenses to keep the virus at Bay
and it is also an important reminder
that no one is safe
until
all of us are safe
ministers have not met the commitments
that were made this summer at the G7 to
get the vaccine rolled out to other
parts of the globe what update can the
Secretary of State give on the
government's Global commitments
and given that Omicron is already here
what we do at home truly matters there
are measures that we can put in place
right now to keep infections down and
ensure the country has the best possible
protection
can he set out the rationale for not
introducing pre-departure testing
surely this would be an effective way of
preventing people traveling with covid
into our country
we support the decision to introduce
masks on public transport and in shops
but we believe this should never have
been abandoned in the first place
a place would always have been our plan
A
State X
it could not spread in pubs
most importantly what is the plan to
enforce mask wearing shop workers
have given so much during the last 20
months alongside our Emergency Services
asking shop workers to enforce mask
wearing is yet another pressure that
they do not need and do not deserve
if masks had been mandatory it would
have been harder for this new variant to
spread
a global study published in the British
medical journal argued that face mask
wearing can bring transmission down as
much as 53 percent
and this government's flip-flopping on
masks has created confusion across
schools colleges and universities so can
the Secretary of State today confirm the
new requirements across all education
settings
and
the prime minister is not the best
person to tell people to wear masks when
he can't even be bothered to wear one
himself when he goes into a hospital
full of vulnerable patience and can I
ask the Secretary of State when
conservative back Ventures will start
wearing their masks
foreign
State update the house on when he
expects there to be a decision on
vaccinations for younger children
as the government has fallen far short
of its own Target to offer all 12 to 15
year olds the vaccine by October half
term so can he say what action will be
taken to speed up vaccine rollout
our NHS have done us proud and have done
a fantastic job to deliver the vaccine
offering first second third and booster
Jabs all at the same time as treating
patients suffering from covid and trying
to recover elective procedures
I'd like to take this time to thank
everyone who works in our NHS and Care
sector
and we're putting even more demands on
them at the moment
our NHS has stepped up to the challenge
and it is a shame that this government
simply hasn't done that
vaccine rates among those with mental
illnesses are low and mortality rates
High
the government needs to stop weaponizing
mental health and instead must recognize
that good clear honest communication is
so important in a crisis something that
they have failed to do so far
and I know and I've mentioned time and
time again
but the government must acknowledge the
trauma for people with severe covert
long covered and NHS staff so where is
their plan
labor has been cleared throughout this
pandemic that proper sick pay will help
people to isolate the government has
chosen to ignore us time and time again
so I ask again
what support will be available to people
who need to self-isolate and is this the
time to finally fix sick pay
I would also appreciate it if the
Secretary of State could update the
house on the new antivirals and how they
will be utilized
and why are the governments not already
giving antibody tests to the
immunocompromised
the situation we find ourselves in now
was entirely predictable
yet again this government have shown
they are incapable of protecting our
communities protecting our NHS and
saving lives
yeah thank you um Mr Speaker first can I
also extend my best wishes to the shadow
Health secretary wishing a speedy
recovery I do have to say Mr Speaker I I
do think the honorable lady has
misjudged the tone of the house
this this is a a very this is a very
serious matter
and and I think the whole country would
be looking for all members of this house
to to work together and to support the
nation and surely she isn't blaming the
the UK government for the emergence of
this new variant
perhaps she was just re uh auditioning
for the reshuffle that's going on in her
party right now but let me let me Mr
Speaker answer answer the questions
around she asked about uh International
donations uh and the UK is leading the
world in international donations quite
rightly so it is absolutely right that
that is treated as a priority uh we
would like to see other countries uh
step up as well the Prime Minister uh
made a pledge a few months back of a
hundred million donations by June uh
2022 uh 80 of those through Kovacs of
which we are a huge supporter and 20
bilateral and so far we have donated
over 20 million more than almost most of
the many other countries and Kovacs as I
said which we an organization we helped
found and we support uh has the donated
I believe some 537 million doses uh to
144 uh different countries uh the the
rules The Honorable lady asked about the
the rules on on travel and masks and
others that I set out well I'll say Mr
Speaker I think I've addressed that I do
believe that they are proportioned and
it's a balanced response on the vaccine
rollout we've just set out a a huge
expansion of the vaccine rollout program
it's a shame that The Honorable lady
could not find it in herself to welcome
That vaccine rollout and as I said I
will set out more details in coming days
on exactly how we intend to to meet the
requirement to to vaccinate more and
then on antivirals we're one of the few
countries in the world that have
procured the two leading antivirals we
were the our regulator the mhra our
independent regulator was the first in
the world to approve one of those
antivirals I'm pleased with the over 700
000 courses that we have for Citizens
across the United Kingdom but of course
given the emergence of this new variant
we'll be reviewing that and seeing if
more needs to be done
show the slight committee Jeremy helmet
thank you Mr Speaker the late Donald
Rumsfeld coined the phrase known
unknowns and that is what we face with
the new Omicron virus so the secretary
stated absolutely right to take sensible
and proportionate measures to buy time
while we are waiting to understand how
dangerous this new variant can be but
does he not agree that the facts that we
are facing this danger is also a symptom
of the failure of Western countries to
make sure that vaccines are distributed
adequately around the world and whilst I
recognize the enormous contribution the
UK has made through Kovacs through the
development of the AstraZeneca vaccine
and so on is it not a moral and
practical failure that richer countries
have managed to vaccinate 60 of their
populations when for poorer countries
it's just three percent
Thursday first of all Mr Speaker can I
thank my wife honorable friend for his
support and I do agree with his uh words
uh it is important that all rich
countries do everything they can to to
support her vaccines and donations of
vaccines to the developing countries
I've said out earlier what the UK has
done and we can be proud of that but we
do need other countries to set up in the
G7 meeting I I chaired earlier today
with uh Health ministers we all agreed
of the importance of this and uh and
about redoubling efforts to make sure
all commitments are met
SMP spokesperson Richard Thompson
thank you Mr Speaker and can I thank the
Secretary of State for advanced sight of
his statement and also add my own thanks
to the work that the NHS does and
continues to do in all parts of these
islands to keep us all healthy and safe
um the merchants of Omicron including
the six cases that we've seen in
Scotland along with the evidence of
Community Transit transmission shows
that this is absolutely no time to be
complacent but for all the measures that
are being taken now at the border day
two PCR testing because of the
incubation period risks missing a number
of these cases passing through the
Border and a more effective approach
surely would be to introduce day eight
PCR testing along with eight days of
isolation to accompany it and it would
surely be better to do that now than to
be bounced into that position by events
further down the line
secondly Mr Speaker the secretary of
state issues a call for us all to work
together which I'm sure we would all
wish to be able to do but I wonder if he
shares my disappointment that when the
first Ministers of Scotland and Wales
today called for a cobra meeting to be
convened that appeared to be dismissed
out of hand already so I wonder will the
Secretary of State Prevail upon the
prime minister to call attend and
convene an urgent Cobra meeting
involving all four nations so that
people might be persuaded that is on top
of this development as we would all
expect them to be
finally I wonder would the Secretary of
State agree with the opposition front
bench and the chair of the select
committee and myself that this emergence
of this variant shows that none of us
are safe until all of us are safe and
that however much is being done and
however much the UK has done to date
more still needs to be done in order to
achieve as close to 100 Global
vaccination as is possible that that not
only includes the vaccination programs
that we're in but it involves increasing
Global vaccine production as well as
overcoming the barriers that patent law
might place in the way of achieving that
first day
Mr Mr Speaker can I first turn to The
Honorable gentleman's question around
the day two testing we do believe that
the uh the day two testing requirement
is the proportion response for
international travel he will know that
it applies to all uh incoming arrivals
into the UK and that the individual
concern would have to self-isolate until
they get a negative test result and I
think that is the the right response
um that in terms of meetings and and UK
Nations working together uh I I think
that has been one of the successes of
the UK response uh to this pandemic uh
the way that uh the Nations across the
UK have worked together especially on
vaccines on testing on surveillance and
antivirals and it shows that we're
stronger together
Greg Cloud thank you very much indeed Mr
Speaker so Andrew Pollard who who
developed the Oxford vaccine predicted
to my Select Committee in June that new
variants would escape the vaccines by
being more infectious but the protection
against severe illness should continue
so will my writable friend avoid taking
any Panic measures if we see a rise in
infections during the weeks ahead as
seems inevitable and concentrate instead
on the vaccine's effectiveness against
severe illness and hospitalization
yeah Mr Speaker I could my right or
friend is absolutely right we have
already as I referred to my statement
even with the dominant Delta variant at
the moment we have seen some rises in
affections but we've been seeing Falls
in hospitalization in death rates uh
thankfully too and the reason for that
is the power of the vaccines especially
our booster program the largest in
Europe so my my right armor friends
absolutely right that what matters as we
look ahead uh around the this new
variant is what matters more than
anything is hospitalizations flyback
thank you Mr Speaker the second line in
the secretary of state statement says
we've always known that a worry new
variant could be a threat to the
progress we've made as a nation with
that in mind does he think it was wrong
for the government to abandon mask
wearing in public places in confined
spaces and Willie listened to the
recommendations of Dorian Lawrence's
report and and start to issue full face
protection masks to care workers and
health workers Thursday
Mr Speaker He's Surely The Honorable
gentleman isn't suggesting that if we'd
worn if we had different rules and masks
over the summer that this new variant
would not have emerged
thank you Mr Speaker I'm sure my right
honorable friend will want to pay
tribute to the South African government
for raising the existence of the Omicron
variant and obviously that has resulted
in then having a travel ban imposed I do
have constituents and in fact family
members stuck in South Africa so can I
write honorable friend tell us how long
he expects cancellations and suspensions
of flights to occur because obviously
for anyone stuck overseas a very
worrying time so
first of all I joined my ride on my
friend in again expressing thanks to the
South African government about how they
have handled this difficult situation
and I also understand what my right
honorable friend has said about her
constitutions many of us will have
constituents in a similar position and
uh it is hard to to say when Flight
direct flights might start but we have
started our a hotel booking program so
that that is one part of trying to get
our citizens back but we will do
everything we can to support them in
that way
they'll revolved
I asked the Secretary of State quite
rightly we praised the South African
doctor but she saw her patient face to
face could I ask the Secretary of State
what advice guidance or instruction he's
going to give to the GPS I know my
constituents in Walter are Keen to see
their GPS face to face but this may be
more effective than test and Trace
Tuesday
Mr Speaker the The Honorable Lady it's a
important question and uh one thing we
are doing at this point here is uh
updating guidance throughout the NHS
including Primary Care
thank you very much Mr Speaker in his uh
statement the Secretary of State said
that
um the legislation that he's laid before
the house which incidentally isn't yet
available on the legislation.gov website
for members to study he said close
contacts of anyone who tests positive
with a suspected case of Omicron the
self-isolate for 10 days regardless of
whether they've been vaccinated can I
just confirm with him first of all that
that is what is in the regulations and
secondly for the benefit of the house
could he set out what he set out
yesterday in the Television Studios the
mechanism by which the variant the
Omicron variant will be identified and
communicated to those people contacted
by test and Trace so that we all know
how this is going to work as it's more
complicated than the system we've had to
date serious state
yeah what I couldn't tell my right older
friend is that the the the the why what
I can confirm is that the regulation on
the new regulation on close contact will
be anyone that is a close contact of
someone that is uh confirmed positive
case of suspected uh Omicron
um the the ukhsa is working at speed
that one of the best ways to determine a
suspected case one of the ways to do
that is to do the so-called SG Dropout
test but there are other quick ways to
ascertain that as well and the the work
in terms of uh tracing will be carried
out by UK test and Tracey Cooper
thank you Mr Speaker it's often said
that how a society treats its most
vulnerable is a measure of its humanity
and yet a quarter of the clinically
extremely vulnerable are yet to have
their third primary dose because of the
confusion that persists between the
third primary dose and the booster one
in five of the clinically extremely
vulnerable are still shielding without
any government guidance or support for
them the uncertainty of the new variant
is quite frankly terrifying so will the
Secretary of State or one of his
ministers please agree to meet with me
and patient groups to discuss our
five-point plan on how we can protect
the clinically extremely vulnerable this
winter
so to start the the vaccines minister is
meeting with patient groups there this
week but she would also be happy to meet
The Honorable lady
Nicole thank you very much Mr Speaker
can I join others in welcoming the
well-judged and Rapid action this
weekend and also welcome the
acceleration of boosters including the
new provision of a Max Mass vaccination
this weekend in Newmarket and while
existing vaccinations including boosters
are effective against all known major
variants before Omicron can he set out
plans for a variant vaccine should it be
needed in the worst case scenario so
stay can I thank my right or my friend
for his uh support when it comes to uh
potentially new vaccines that is a a
program that the UK has been supporting
it largely thanks to his efforts when uh
he was in my position and that work
continues and if if it is necessary to
procure new vaccines that we believe are
safe and effective and will help this
new variant we will do so Sarah
thank you Mr Speaker Gordon Brown said
yesterday that the chief medical officer
urgently needs to teach the Prime
Minister some basic medical facts I'd
say that could probably be extended to
some of those on the back benches
opposite as well
meaning we're not going to stop the
threat of variants
Mr shelbrook I thought you might be
going on the NATO delegation and I don't
want to that you've missed out on it
please
thank you Mr Speaker we're not going to
stop the threat of variants derailing
our progress until we vaccinate the
world our country has enough vaccine to
give at least three doses to everybody
yet of the 100 million doses that were
pledged by the prime minister to the
world's poorest less than 10 percent
have actually been delivered so can the
Secretary of State tell us if the PM
will meet his ambition to help vaccinate
the World by the end of 2021 or is this
yet another broken promise with
catastrophic consequences
foreign
Mr Speaker I think I I did say earlier
out of the 100 million commitment the UK
has made for international donations
over 20 million have already gone been
delivered and there's another 10 million
about to go you're married
thank you Mr Speaker the return of PCR
testing will be met with some
apprehension by the international travel
sector which has just been getting back
onto its feet but they will at least be
cheered by the secretary of state
statement that we won't keep measures in
place for a day longer than is necessary
can I ask the Secretary of State to
ensure that the providers of PCR test
are those that will actually give
accurate good value uh testing back to
the public and we will not see some of
the issues that Rose uh over the summer
repeat themselves Thursday Mr Speaker my
my normal friend makes a very important
point I know he rightly takes a close
interest in this and we do want to
minimize any impact on our excellent
transport and try travel sector and he's
right to raise the the importance of
making sure that PCR tests are available
the pricing is is correct and that the
the government website where they're
listed is properly monitored so if
anyone who breaks the rules is delisted
Barbara Keely
thank you Mr Speaker although the
measures taken so far are welcome now
that we have Community transmission of
Omicron in Brentwood and in Scotland we
need more protective interventions mask
wearing can obviously play an important
part so can the Secretary of State say
whether he agrees with the call from the
BMA to extend this to all indoor and
closed settings and we'll see also
consider measures to increase
ventilation in enclosed settings
encourage working from home and give
proper sick pay for those who need to
isolate Thursday
I think Mr Speaker we've been clear
about why we have set up the new rules
on masks I think our response is the
proportionate one uh when it comes to
ventilation The Honorable ladies right
to raise the importance of that that's
why it's very clear in guidelines and
many places are following that and when
it comes to sick pay it's right that uh
that we've kept rules in place that
allow people uh should they uh be tested
positive or have to self-isolate that
they can claim sick pay from day one
three civilians
if the situation deteriorates and we all
hope it won't but if it does please can
the governor do everything possible not
to shut down the hospitality and event
sector again millions of people have
their livelihoods depend on this they're
just getting back on their feet please
let us not knock them down again
Tuesday Mr Speaker I agree absolutely
with my right on my friend
thank you Mr Speaker and the emergence
of Omicron is not really a much of a
surprise it's more a case of when not if
and anecdotal evidence from South Africa
suggests that uh whilst it may be more
infectious the potency does seem to be
more limited and the particular concern
is the mutations so the spike protein in
two specific areas and I just wonder
what um action the government are taking
to put additional resources into
adjuvant therapy development
particularly given the impact on
monoclonal antibody therapies and the
vaccine and what is the status of
genomic surveillance in the UK at
present Tuesday
Mr Speaker first I think it's fair to
say that our genomic surveillance has
never been so strong and it was getting
stronger even before the pandemic but
because of the pandemic there's been a
huge amount of investment and it's paid
off uh UK wide in terms of the the
treatments there is some concern around
this new variant and uh rhonoprive which
is one of the key monoclonal antibodies
that we use for treatment but it is just
concern at this point there's no
particular evidence but part of the
reason for taking these measures is to
buy the time that we need the the two
weeks or so two three weeks to to give
our scientists time to assess the the
risk of this variant properly
speaker what assessment has the
Secretary of State made of those early
reports from South Africa that the
variant may actually lead to less severe
illness than the previous variants and
secondly can I welcome the fact we have
both a debate and a vote tomorrow on
these regulations but wouldn't it be
better if we had the debate and the vote
before the restrictions come into Force
rather than after yeah
Mr Speaker to in response to my right
angle friend the the in terms of the the
debate and the vote tomorrow I believe
the leader will be making a statement uh
on that uh shortly uh I think right
after my statement
um in terms of the uh the severity these
there are reporters my right all my
friend is refer to uh that it is early
days in terms of those reports and we
are looking into those and talking
actually with our South African friends
and getting more details I think it is
worth pointing out that the the the age
profile the demographics in South Africa
is is generally people on average are
younger we are taking that into account
as well well
thank you Mr Speaker
the Secretary of State have set out in
his statement this afternoon about the
booster program for the vaccines but he
hasn't mentioned what steps he's going
to be taking to support those areas
where take-up of the vaccine is still
very low so can he Now set out what
additional resources will be provided to
those areas where we know that the
take-up of the vaccine is still very low
[Music]
it's it's an important Point Mr Speaker
the right The Honorable ladies right to
to raise him there are still we estimate
around 5 million people across the UK
that have not even taken up the offer of
their first dose of the vaccine putting
themselves and their loved ones at Great
risk in terms of action there's a lot of
work that's been done over the last few
months it is bearing resolved we are
seeing more and more people come forward
especially in the last few weeks and
indeed we saw many come forward this
weekend perhaps out of concern of this
new variant but there's a lot of work
being done with Community leaders
there's a there's been an existing
Communications campaigned but there's a
new one about to start imminently
so Desmond's way over the last few
months has been a useful control
experiment on face coverings given the
different policies pursued in Scotland
and England what estimate has he made of
the result it's mumbo jumbo isn't it
Thursday I think if if my run over
friend is suggesting uh that there they
are a mixed views on on the the efficacy
of face coverings in in helping to fight
this pandemic he would be right but I I
would Point him to to uh a work that's
already been said about ukhsc I think it
was published if I remember correctly
last month where they refer to a number
of reports where they set out in certain
settings how face coverings could help
Castle blacks speaker what urgent action
is being taken to vaccinate people who
are bed bound
so state for Mr Speaker for such
individuals the the bed bound homebound
or vulnerable for other reasons and
can't make it to vaccination centers
those vaccinations are primarily carried
out by GPS uh I don't have the numbers
of how many have actually been done but
recently to encourage more people to be
done more quickly we did change the
payment system for GPS and that seems to
have helped as well Aaron Bell thank you
Mr Speaker the opposition often called
for more restrictions but uh it was the
relaxation of restrictions in the summer
that this government took under
scientific advice that has put Britain
in a good position
so while I welcomed the statement and
the precautionary and proportionate
measures he's taken today will the
Secretary of State assume and the house
that this is a temporary measure and
when we get more information when we
bought more time we will get new
measures to react to that information
yes I'm very happy to give that
Assurance to my Ottawa friend he's he's
absolutely right and this is all about
buying buying a bit of time so our
scientists get the the the time that
they need to properly assess uh this uh
variant and determine what it really is
should we really be worried about it or
or not uh but he's also right Mr Speaker
to point out that we did take measures
in the Summer where we set out or that
we were removing almost all domestic
rules and controls they turned out to be
absolutely the right measures there's
many of my uh counterparts in Europe
that now they believe that they should
have taken a similar route as well but I
do remember they were all opposed by the
party offices
thank you Mr Speaker
immunocompromised people continue to be
worried many still don't know if the
vaccine works on them the architect
study showed that around 150 000 people
potentially have reduced or no antibody
response octave Duo is not juicer or
until early next year will the Secretary
of Street estate ensure this population
have access to antibody tests thus
allowing them to know their level of
protection and for those with little or
no protection will he ensure that they
have the support they need to stay safe
yes of course Mr Speaker we want to make
sure that we are helping people that are
immunosuppressed in every way that is
possible including access to any test
that might be clinically required she
The Honorable lady may have noted
earlier in the jcvi advice that I refer
to that there's also a recommendation
which we have accepted to say that those
that are immunosuppressed that do are
able to benefit from vaccine to some
extent that they are offered a booster
dose on top of the the third primary
dose and then also the antivirals are
are very important for that particular
group of vulnerable people and it's good
that the UK has procure them Bob Sealy
thank you Mr Speaker um will the
Secretary of State on behalf of
government reassure me that the foreign
office and the conscious Consular
service in the foreign office will be
doing all that it's all that it can
because I'm already receiving course
from Islanders stuck in southern Africa
who are worried about their ability to
get back thank you sexual resources yes
Mr Speaker I can give my honorable
friend that Assurance we have been
working closely with with colleagues in
in the foreign office and it will remain
vital work so we can help people UK
citizens or Irish citizens that might be
stuck aboard to come back interesting
hello Ben
yeah thank you very much Mr Speaker
given the change to the rules for
booster vaccinations and amps by the
jcvi this afternoon
how long does the Secretary of State
think it will be before all the people
who've had their first and second Jabs
come forward and can receive the booster
jab from age 18 to age 40 so as much of
the population as possible is protected
uh Mr Speaker first if I could tell the
right honorable gentlemen that we've
already done 17 million and and that is
um almost uh one third of the adult
population it's more than any other
country in Europe but he's right to ask
how quickly could we do the the those
that are will become newly eligible if
he uh allows me I will have to come back
to the house uh and and set out details
about how we intend to meet this advice
we this advice was uh uh very quickly uh
received from the jcbi over the weekend
they did Stellar work to turn it around
so quickly but uh I have already asked
the NHS about operationalize again and
uh we're not quite there yet but we will
be very shortly and I will set that out
Richard Drax
speaker none of us underplayed the
threat of any new variant and as my
right or my friend said today
covert is not going to go away it's not
it's here for the rest of our lives the
country is learning to live with this
disease now it is the only way forward
can you please reassure me the house and
the country that he will never ever go
back to locking this country down
Mr Speaker I mean no one wants to see
those kind of measures but the The
Honorable gentleman I'm sure will it
will agree with me that it will first
let me agree with him that your covid is
is with us to stay and we need to learn
to live with it and the best way I think
we can do that is uh with the primary
form of defense that we've got which is
our vaccination program and I hope he
agrees with you we're absolutely right
to to basically put the booster program
on steroids because that will really
help us
thank you Mr Speaker one of the most
covered vulnerable settings in the
country is School classrooms and
children have a much much lower
vaccination rate than adults and
children come from all over communities
to one place and then return in the
afternoon to families now masks are
being returned to uh corridors but
they're not being returned to classrooms
I take no pleasure in advising the
Secretary of State to make children wear
masks in classrooms however it is
absolutely clear what the stakes are
going to be if we get this wrong
students have already been absent from
schools in by their hundreds of
thousands this term and we are
approaching the exam season if we just
act cautiously in the next few days
exams will be able to be set as normal
if we get this wrong exams will be
wrecked for the third year running and
that will be a Havoc with their Futures
and it'll play Havoc with the with
teachers and their ability to get the
job done on behalf of our country
Thursday
Mr Speaker the original know that we the
education department has set out uh
today your fresh guidance on masks in
communal areas not in classrooms I think
that is the right approach that the
government has set out and uh but in
terms of protecting children from this
pandemic you know the the vaccination
program of children is important
especially secondary school children 12
to 15 year olds it's uh I think around
over 40 percent have been vaccinated it
has certainly increased since we opened
up the national booking system to that
cohort and I think for 16 17 year olds
it's almost 60 now but we continue to
work on it Andrew Bridge
speaker my rightful friend has outlined
the government response to the emergence
of the Omicron variant and the
restrictions that he wishes to place on
the public this house will quite rightly
have a vote on these measures he's also
stated that these measures will be
reviewed in three weeks time he knows
that in three weeks time this house will
be in recess how will there be a
parliamentary scrutiny of the
government's review measures or will we
be having government by dictat
so stay well Mr Speaker I think that the
review should take place as soon as
possible and that is how the government
determined its three weeks and unless
Parliament was called back from Recess
or the government took longer than three
weeks uh there's no way I think the the
approach the government set out is the
right one good right Lucas thank you
very much Mr Speaker the secretary says
that rich countries must do everything
they can to ensure more vaccines reach
the global South judging by his actions
he means doing everything except the
main thing they're actually asking for
which is the waving of intellectual
property rules at the World Trade
Organization so that they can
manufacture vaccines themselves this is
about Justice not about charity so will
he admit that his government's failure
to work for the vast majority of
countries in the world including the
United States who do support a trips
waiver at the WTO is endangering us all
and when will he start putting the need
to end this pandemic in front of the
financial interests of big Pharma
Mr Speaker yeah I've heard what the
Ottawa lady had to say but the the UK
does not believe that waving patent
rights here the intellectual property
rights uh to those that on these
vaccines would be helpful uh it would
certainly mean that in the future uh
there will be a huge disincentive for
vaccine companies pharmaceutical
companies that come forward and help the
world with their technology
Sir Charles Walker I think the Secretary
of State injecting people not just in
this country but around the world is a
huge logistical undertaking I believe in
India they use nasal vaccines for the
administration of the flu vaccine please
can the government bring forward nasal
vaccines we did it in nine months for an
injectable vaccine March 2020 to
December 2020. it's now nearly December
21 and still no nasal vaccine despite in
Trials high levels of efficacy being
proven
so stay Mr Speaker my honorable friend
is right to raise the importance of
vaccine delivery mechanisms and I
believe if there was a a An approved
nasal vaccine delivery mechanism then it
would be helpful but he will understand
we do have to allow The Regulators the
time to assess new delivery mechanisms
but we do take this very seriously
Abraham
speaker and I wholeheartedly agree that
no one is safe until we are all safe and
I think the the UK and other G7
countries need to take some
responsibility for the emergence of this
variant but I just wanted to touch on
the fact we already have a community
spread of this uh variant and if we're
going to contain that we must ensure
that contact tracing is is a relevant
and is a is a widespread widespread as
possible so can the Secretary of State
I've asked him this in the last few
weeks confirm
the containment outbreak management fund
will be extended Beyond March and for
those places that don't have it that
they will have it and of course those
that have already spent it will be able
to be properly resourced thank you
so The Honorable lady makes an important
point about compact contact tracing in
terms of the containment management
outbreak fund especially given the
emergence of this variant we are
actively reviewing it
Steve Prime
very much sir
um I welcome the widening of the booster
program that he's announced but my
constituents still have to have no
walk-in access in Winchester so I'd
really appreciate his help with that on
behalf of an increasing number of
constituents contacting me now the
measures that will be asked to approve
tomorrow night will likely appear rather
small in in and of themselves but he
knows the wider impact of the past few
days is absolutely huge you know we've
got Nativity plays canceled or moved
online these are moments that we just
don't get back and community events
being canceled just in case so the Prime
Minister said this lunchtime if you're
boosted we know your response to this
variant is strong so can I ask my right
honorable friend what evidence base this
is drawn from and when we might
reasonably expect data from the
scientists on how if at all the variant
hits vaccine efficacy
first of all I know what my honorable
friend said Mr Speaker about walking
access and Hampshire so I will take that
away and get back to him secondly on in
terms of he's also right to talk about
the impact of these measures although as
I said I believe they are a right and
proportionate and balanced we must never
forget the impact they have on
individuals and uh and their daily lives
and that is why they must be removed the
moment it is safe to remove them and in
terms of when we will have more data the
the reason we set a three-week review
point is that is the time that we
believe that we will have more
information not just the information
we've come up with ourselves but through
our International counterparts
Redemption thank you Mr Speaker first of
all can I thank the Secretary of State
on his team for all to do to combat
covid-19 decisions in the UK it has an
effect upon Northern aren't they
Northern Health Minister just yesterday
said they will follow and or now the
guidance comes from Westminster so with
that in mind having heard a leading note
9 scientists as we say that he believes
the current vaccination and booster
rollout will have an effect on a new
variant could the Secretary of State
assure us that any and all curtailment
such as those faced by the travel
industry currently will be proportionate
and scientific taking into account
transmission and the seriousness of the
new covet vaccine variation thank you so
stay
yes Mr Speaker I can give the honorable
choice Dr Julian Lewis
thank you Mr Speaker as someone who very
thankfully received his booster jab last
Thursday in the outstanding St Thomas's
Hospital can I ask him why it is that
certain groups and communities seem to
fear vaccination which are these groups
and communities and what can be done to
persuade them that they're wrong
so to stay Mr Speaker my I can tell my
right or my friend that the uh there are
many uh communities where vaccine
take-up is is lower than others and it
has been particularly the case in the
black African Community in Britain and
also uh some other black minority ethnic
communities it has improved
significantly uh over uh the the last uh
two to three months and it is something
that is also the case in many of the
European countries and indeed the US in
terms of what's being done is a huge
amount of work through Community leaders
and uh through uh Communications
campaign and also by offering access in
many different ways as possible uh to
the vaccine to encourage take up Andrew
Gwen
thank you can the Secretary of State
talk a bit more about the
transmissibility of the Omicron variant
and the efficacy of vaccines to it given
Australia has some of the toughest entry
requirements of any country in the world
and yet this variant has basically got
through a concrete wall
Thursday it's an important Point Mr
Speaker by The Honorable gentleman is
that I think it's fair to say we don't
know enough yet and I don't think the
Australia does we do or any other
country for that matter but we do know
enough to justify the action that's been
taken and uh and from that there is
emerging evidence that it is more
transmissible but I I I don't think it's
we can describe it as conclusive at this
point and in terms of efficacy I would
just uh point to the the point I made
earlier to my honorable friend about
taking the time to determine the
efficacy
Jason McCartney uh thank you Mr Speaker
I welcome the speedy and decisive action
taken by the government over the weekend
in response to this new variant I also
welcome the delivery of 17 and a half
million boosters and will this Secretary
of State join me in thanking not only my
Pharmacy LED vaccination centers where I
had my first and second doses of AZ but
also my GP LED clinics where I have my
Pfizer booster and is he confident that
that infrastructure is in place and also
the robust supply of vaccines as we try
and deliver six million more booster
vaccines over the next three weeks
regular State Mr Speaker I mean first of
all when it comes to supply we're very
confident about the supply that we have
including accommodating the the new
advice that I've accepted from jcvi and
I would join him in thanking the many
thousands of GPS across the country that
have been crucial to our vaccine program
Mr Speaker can I just take a moment to
just my honorable right honorable friend
the the member foreign earlier asked me
about the regulations and the timing of
the lane of the regulations and I want
to clarify that there are regulations
for these new measures they have been
made by my honorable friend the minister
for public health and vaccines and they
are in the process of being registered
with the National Archives and then they
will be laid before Parliament and they
should be available to review online at
around 5 PM Chris Brown thank you Mr
Speaker it doesn't feel like this
pandemic is going to be over anytime
soon I mean we've only got to Omicron
not to Omega so far and can I urge the
Secretary of State to look at two
particular things the first is the
campaign of disinformation deliberate
campaign of disinformation that is going
on around the country some of these
people are dangerous their views are
certainly dangerous and I hope that he
will work with the Home Secretary to
make sure that we check on all of these
campaigns around the new Nuremberg laws
that nobody is going to be doing damage
to people who are working in the Health
Service and secondly can he tackle the
problem of profiteering because frankly
some of the companies are charging
completely disproportionate prices now
for PCR tests there should surely be a
fixed price across the whole of the UK
Thursday
Mr Speaker The Honorable gentleman is a
very good point about the danger of
disinformation How It's actually costing
lives not just here in the UK but but
across the world and uh he will know for
example you know we've talked today a
lot about South Africa rightly but
there's a there's a there's a very low
vaccine take up in South Africa even
when they are available partly due to
these uh the this disinformation
campaign and I'm I can assure we're
working across government with the home
office with dcms and others to to
counter this kind of disinformation as
best as we can and on PCR tests I refer
them to the remarks I made a moment ago
thank you Mr Speaker I congratulate my
right honorable friend for taking Swift
and efficient action in relation to the
additional protections that are
necessary but as he reviews the wearing
of face masks and the additional
restrictions is introduced as more data
becomes available will you also consider
real life scenarios because as he's
heard calls from Members opposites about
mask wearing and working from home is he
aware that in Wales mask wearing and
working from home has still been in
place since the summer yet infection
rates are still much higher
is right to raise a difference in terms
of the approach that Wales has taken in
England I feel I think like him that we
have taken the right approach uh to face
Mass but I welcome his support today
well
thank you Mr Speaker my rightful friend
rightly uh highlights the uh the role
that South Africa's excellent testing
and Analysis system has had in
identifying Omicron it would be perverse
if South Africa was treated less
favorably as a result of the resources
they put into such analyzes so will he
go back and look at those countries that
are neighboring Red List countries that
have much lower testing and Analysis uh
levels and see whether travel
restrictions might be appropriate for
some of those countries in order to keep
people in this country safe serve state
Mr Speaker we we will keep that under
review but my honorable friend is also
right to raise uh again like many
members have across the house the the
importance of South Africa and how it
has handled this in such a professional
and exemplary way and uh to he might
reassure him to know that in the G7
meeting I tread earlier we all agree
unanimously on that and the importance
of continuing to work and to support the
South Africa
Stephen King
thank you Mr Speaker we know that if the
government just sits back and waits for
to buy a development of new vaccines for
new variants then we'll be left at the
back of the queue because industry will
always go to the highest bidder such as
the EU or the us back in April Clive
dicks the outgoing head of the vaccine
task force sent the government a
specific proposal about a new task force
to set be set up to Fast Track the
development of new vaccines for new
variants yesterday Mr Dix revealed that
the government's completely failed to
respond to his proposal can the
Secretary of State explain why the
government's chosen to ignore Mr Dix's
expert advice
Tuesday Mr Speaker I don't think it'd be
great to say the the government has
ignored the advice that The Honorable
gentleman uh has referred to and also I
think it would be incorrect for him to
uh or to refer to or to say that the
government has somehow when it comes to
vaccines I think he said it's it's sit
back and waits you know I I just
mentioned earlier the huge expansion the
vaccine program on the back of the
advice from the jcvi and the fact that
the UK has the supply already to meet
that the reason that we have that is
because we have a fantastic vaccine task
force better than any other country in
the world Trisha Gibbs Mr Speaker most
countries in Africa miss the World
Health Organization Target for a mere 10
of their populations to be vaccinated by
the end of last month as they struggle
to secure supplies of vaccine
as the minister as a secretary of state
here today no one is safe until everyone
is safe what more will his government do
with International Partners to ramp up
the sharing of vaccines with the
developing countries to lessen the risk
of further varying emergence and what
support can be given to developing
countries to tackle the mistrust among
some sectors of these populations
towards the vaccine yeah yeah so stay
Mr Speaker the G7 call I had today we
all agreed or all members about the
importance of of this issue working with
uh developing countries with not just
providing the vaccine but I hope the
honorable lady would agree looking at
what more can be done in actual once the
country has the vaccine delivering it
locally whether it's local Logistics or
other delivery mechanisms and we will be
working hard to see what more we can do
together Robert health
thank you Mr Speaker
um could I just ask my right on a friend
I thank for what he is doing but given
that as I understand it that children
are very little risk from this new
variant so can I just ask him to confirm
that the schools will not be closed any
earlier
Christmas holidays and if I could just
ask him about the mask policy
um can he explain given that masks
aren't required for offices can you
explain this scientific evidence
um in which he decision was made to ask
students to wear masks in corridors
seriously Mr Speaker I mean first of all
when it comes to the the risk to
Children uh from covid in general it is
a lot less thankfully than it is uh to
adults uh with with regard to this
specific new very we just don't know
enough uh about it yet to talk
specifically about potential impact on
children
um there are no plans uh that I am aware
of uh that would require us to to you
know close schools early I I think that
would be very detrimental to the
education of uh children and uh in terms
of rules around masks then right on my
friend will know that the rules that
have been set out today by the
department for Education uh our guidance
for schools in in communal areas and
it's something uh in terms of evidence
that the Department of Education will be
able to provide with more information on
Big whistle thank you Mr Speaker if
we're to win this fight against The
Umbreon variant then it's absolutely
essential that people comply with public
Health guidance but with the UK strategy
set play ranking amongst the lowest in
Europe there are far too many people in
this country who simply cannot afford to
self-isolate will the Secretary of State
commit to working with college in the
cabinet to raise the rate of sick pay so
at least the equivalence of a week's
living wage so that no one is forced to
choose between the right thing and
heating their homes at Christmas Tuesday
Mr Speaker The Honorable gentle will
will know that we have kept the rules in
place that will allow people to claim
sick day sick pay from from day one in
terms of if whether further support is
needed we keep that under review and
we'll provide further support if it was
necessary student Metcalf
but thank you Mr Speaker
um can I thank my right honorable friend
for the work he's been doing and the
speed with which he's been doing it
however can he confirm to my
constituents that as soon as more is
known about this new variant and if it
is deemed to be less of a threat than
first thought as is starting to emerge
from the evidence from South Africa and
the people who I first identified it
that he will act swiftly to remove
restrictions particularly the one around
self-isolation regardless of vaccine
status particularly in the run-up to
Christmas yeah Thursday yes Mr Speaker I
can give my honorable friend that
Assurance Dave Dana Johnson uh yeah
thank you Mr Speaker um I wondered if
the Secretary of State could tell us his
opinion on whether every member of this
house in the chamber should be wearing a
mask
so State Mr Speaker all members of this
house know what the guidance is and it's
a decision for them James Sunderland
Mr Speaker like many in this place I
welcome the statement today and I agree
that further measures and restrictions
would only be a necessary evil could I
please ask Secretary of State to
acknowledge the many millions of people
and businesses right across the UK who
are clawing back their jobs their
livelihoods and their freedoms after a
difficult two years does he agree that
these further restrictions should only
be an absolute Last Resort
Mr Speaker I do agree with my honorable
friend and we we all know from our
experience with this pandemic thus far
uh the the restrictions whilst uh many
of them may well be necessary to to
fight covid they do have uh other
impacts especially on the economy the
life chances of people uh on child's
education social life and also I'm very
much aware of the impact that it's had
on non-covered health outcomes so I very
much agree with what my honorable friend
has said Matt Rhonda
thank you Mr Speaker I would like to
welcome the government's plans to extend
the vaccination program however with our
NHS under severe pressure after two very
difficult years what extra resources is
the Secretary of State willing to put
forward to support our Frontline NHS
particularly our GPS the ambulance
services and a e
speaker we have provided just this year
alone an additional 34 billion pounds of
support to the NHS and the social care
system and each of the areas The
Honorable gentleman just mentioned
whether it's the GPS or the winter
access fund the support to ambulance
trust I think uh over 55 billion pounds
for the winter pressures all that extra
funding is in place and it's making a
real difference
thank you thank you very much Mr Speaker
she said fighting with her mask
um having received my booster
vaccination yesterday I would like to
thank Lester Leicester Sharon Rutland
vaccination service and particularly
Rachel and Abby for their excellent work
would my right honorable friend agree
with me that it is vital that
constituents take up their vaccinations
including the booster to help us all
through the winter period
yes I do Mr Speaker the the vaccines
remain our primary line of defense I
congratulate her on uh getting her
booster shot yesterday but I absolutely
agree with her wholeheartedly that
everyone that is eligible should come
forward protect themselves and protect
their loved ones
thank you Mr Speaker without in country
manufacturing of the vaccine in the
global South we will never get the
protection we need against this pandemic
and supplies no matter how much how many
donations the government may make will
never meet the demand and therefore will
he again look at the issue about
in-country manufacturing whether that's
release of the patent or through other
mechanisms so that we can see a proper
scale up in the global south of the
delivery of this vaccine
I think Mr Speaker The Honorable lady's
right to talk about the importance of
in-country manufacturing in in the
developing world she will know for
example that India is one of the largest
manufacturers of vaccines including
covid-19 vaccine but she rightly points
to that growing and being available to
other countries and is right to look to
see how we can support that
I welcome the acceleration of the
booster program but can I ask the
Secretary of State to do all he can to
accelerate the approval by the jcbi of
the vaccine for under 12 particularly
the clinically extremely vulnerable I
have a constituent who's seven he's
desperate to go to school without fear
all his parents want is to be able to
give him a jab so stay
the my honorable lady The Honorable
friend is right to to raise that and I
hope she'll agree with me the jci has
acted very quickly uh uh since the the
emergence of this new variant and if
there are other things that can be taken
forward to to help uh vaccinate the
population we will certainly be looking
at that with great interest
thank you I think the Secretary of State
briefly mentioned hotel bookings in a
much nonsense a much earlier question
but he'll be aware that over the weekend
there were reports of a shortage of
quarantine Hotel spaces how is he going
to ensure that this doesn't undermine
his reasonable attempts at a rapid
response to the new variant and where
does someone currently find Reliable
information about the capacity and
availability of such accommodation
what so State Mr Speaker the the
department already had contingency plans
in place uh if if countries were rapidly
added to the Red List uh I believe uh
some over 600 rooms were made available
on uh on on the Sunday morning and
that's rapidly going to increase uh
during the next few days I think it has
already increased uh since then and in
terms of information it's available I
believe most of it is available on the
government website Dr Ben Spencer thank
you Mr Speaker and I thank my uncle
friend for his statement I included the
problem here is uncertainty I welcome
the analysis and the three-week review
and ambition to do it sooner but
following on from uh the question from
my humble friend the member from
Northwest leicestershire if the review
takes place after this house has risen
does he agree with me that we should be
recalled to debate its findings yeah so
Mr Speaker I think that is a decision we
will have to make closer to the time
nice twist
thank you Mr Speaker
um with the additional the new
restrictions being brought in it is shot
workers and workers on Transport
Services who will bear the brunt of uh
asking people to comply what measures
does the government propose to ensure
that those workers get the protection
that they deserve state
Mr Speaker these new rules on uh face
coverings uh that they they will be
enforceable by by law
they the the police and other law
enforcement authorities will be able to
issue penalty notices I think the
penalty starts at 200 pound I I think
that that should be a last resort uh but
if if necessary then of course it should
be enforced let's learn
Mr Speaker my North Devon constituents
are Keen to get boosted with a big queue
last night at the Barnstaple Leisure
Center vaccination drop-in but whilst
delighted the booster program is being
extended please can my right honorable
friend reassure me that more help will
be given to rural constituencies like
mine where residents are struggling to
get local appointments despite the hard
work of the ccg and vaccination teams
Thursday first I'm head I'm really
pleased to hear that her Constitutions
are so keen and I can also assure her of
that support especially as we now expand
the booster program on the back of the
latest jcbi advice
sir Tony Lloyd thank you Mr Speaker can
the the secretary state will know very
well that the the Omicron
variation was just added alarm to people
who were immune compromised particularly
when they're uncertain about the status
of whether their third jab was a booster
or a specific one for immuno compromised
position there are also people with
anomalous positions with respect to
vaccinations how can as members of
parliament we get fast track information
through his departments about what is
right for individual anomalous
constituents
so state
well um
Mr Speaker most people in that situation
uh they they would be contacted either
by letter or directly by their GPS but I
do understand the importance of the
question and uh The Honorable may have
heard earlier that one of the pieces of
advice from the jcbi that I've accepted
is that those that are severely
immunocompromised that have received
three doses as part of their their
primary course are also now offered a a
booster dose as well so a fourth uh dose
as long as it's been a three month Gap
since their third dose in many cases if
an individual is unsure I think the best
place for advice is their own GP if the
honorable gentleman would find it
helpful to meet with the vaccines
Minister and get more information we can
set that up as well
Mr shelburn thank you Mr Speaker my
office will thank my wonderful friend
for his statement today and could I ask
my right-handled friend
um he mentioned about reviewing the
evidence as quickly as possible and
asking would that include evidence from
20 countries who have had this um
variant before it got here I may also
ask my right and old friend about flu
because there's been many Health
academics who have said that the
virulence of flu is growing with the
separation that we're doing in wearing
masks Etc and our actual immunity is not
tackling fluid the way it used to
because we're not mixing so with the
right attention being given to um covid
because my rod and friend what also is
happening looking at other viruses such
as the flu and what plans may in place
if a very villainous strain for that may
take yeah first of all Mr Speaker I can
tell my honorable friend that in terms
of the the the work that's being done on
this uh variant it's being done not just
in the UK but by our friends across the
world in fact in the G7 meeting that I
had earlier today we all agreed to
cooperate and share whatever information
that we get and he's also right to raise
the importance of the flu vaccine I'm
glad he has to remind the house that
whilst we have been talking
understandably about the importance of
the covered vaccine booster vaccines in
particular that the the flu vaccine also
remains vitally important this winter
and that's one reason why we have the
largest flu vaccination program this
country's ever seen
very grateful Mr Speaker I'm pleased to
hear that there are no plans to close
schools but can I ask what assessment
has the government made of the potential
for new self-isolation requirements that
could keep children out of school and
what steps will be taken to mitigate
time out of Education because our
children and young people can just not
afford to spend any more time away from
their educational settings
so Mr Speaker we will keep these of
course these self-isolation requirements
the new requirements under review at
this point in time I think very very few
children would be affected because as
she knows the new requirements only
apply to someone who's a close contact
who's tested uh positive with a
suspected case uh of this new variant
but it is something we will keep under
review and the education of children
will always be a huge priority
now come to statement from the leader of
the house we have a business statement
[Music]
[Applause]
um thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to make
a short business statement following the
statement that's just been made by my
right old friend the Secretary of State
for health tomorrow's business will now
be a debate to approve the health
protection coronavirus wearing of face
coverings England regulations 2021 and
the health protection coronavirus
restriction self-isolation England
amendment number four regulations 2021
followed by opposition day ninthal
naughty Day part one there will be a
debate on a motion in the name of the
Scottish national party the business for
the rest of the week remains unchanged
to that previously announced and I shall
make a further business statement in the
usual way on Thursday
I know come to the shuttling and thank
you Mr Speaker and I thank the leader
for advanced site of his statement on
the change of business and of course
we're pleased that this is happening so
quickly
um the questions that came up in the
discussion around the statement that
we've just heard show that there are
issues which will need to be debated and
this debate scheduling this debate so
promptly means that there will be an
opportunity for those questions to be
made and and discussed
um there are also questions about the
rules on education which I think I heard
the secretary of state right there is
going to be a statement from the
secretary state for Education
um if not I think because there are
constituents asking questions of members
across the house and certainly that came
up in the briefing I think on on
Saturday which the Secretary State
kindly gave if it's possible to know
will there be a further briefing on
education will that be separate from
this and could I also asked just a very
technical thing how long the leader is
intending to allow for the debate
tomorrow and so that so that members can
sort of be aware of what exactly is the
timing that it's what's likely to happen
thank you very much Mr Speaker
I'm grateful for the kind words of the
Shadow leader we gave a commitment to
debate matters of national importance as
soon as possible and therefore
delivering on that commitment the debate
tomorrow will be three hours and there
will be three hours of protected time
for the debate in the name of the
Scottish national party
um my right hand did refer to education
in his comments and the importance of
education and protecting children but I
will pass on the right The Honorable
lady's request for more details to my
right and from the Secretary of State
for education
foreign
first of all can I thank the leader for
setting out organizing a debate for
tomorrow and for it being three hours
long rather than the 90 minutes required
by Statute I think that's welcome
um can I just press him a little though
on what the Secretary of State said in
his statement he said this was a point
raised by my honorable friend for
Northwest leicestershire and my
honorable friend for Runnymede and
waybridge Secretary of State said that
we'd be reviewed the government would be
reviewing all the measures that were set
out today after three weeks that takes
us to Monday the 20th of December which
is in The Recess now I hope that the
secretary state will be able to allow
these measures to lapse but if he is
going to re feel that he needs to renew
them or Worse have to bring in stronger
measures can I have a commitment from
the leader that the house will be
recalled to debate and vote on measures
ahead of them coming into Advance he
will know over the last couple employees
particularly due to the way the
government handled the standards
measures there has been a diminution in
the trust between back benches and
ministers and I think giving a clear
commitment to treat Parliament seriously
would help heal that Rift
Mr Speaker Madam Deputy speaker
that my right old friend is I think
being a little
unfair on the government because he will
recall as he was part of these
discussions as was I and as was the the
former Secretary of State for health in
assuring the house that it would get to
debate and vote upon important National
measures and bringing forward the debate
tomorrow I think is a statement of how
importantly I personally and others in
government take that commitment that it
is only right that this house should
approve
um it matters of that kind there was of
course a caveat in that agreement which
is that we needed sometimes to act
during recesses now actually mostly that